this man is worth 5 billion
564 million 800
000 berries how much is that you ask
well
given that one berry is pretty much the
exact same as 1 yen and
100 yen or about 1 american dollar that
would make gold d
rogers head worth about 55.6
million dollars in other words catching
roger would have bought you
this nice little yak about 1 500
bitcoins
or 55 million pieces of
okay tasting gum something by the way
that sounds a lot like a mr beast video
this is a professional bounty hunter not
surprisingly it is by far the highest
bounty we've seen in the story so far
and with the notable exceptions of luffy
and his father dragon there doesn't seem
to be anyone out there right now who
will
ever be able to match it as the first
pirate king and the only known captain
to ever reach the end of the grand line
it is to be expected that roger would
have a high bounty
but being a great adventurer and
notorious pirate alone doesn't explain
the bounty that in the one piece world
would
basically make you royalty the reason
gold raja was so
infamous and dangerous to the world
government then lies within his
character
that tells us a lot about where luffy's
heading in the story as well
it's a story about freedom about power
about camaraderie
about politics history and the most
infamous treasure in the worlds the one
piece itself
this is the story of the pirate king
himself the story of
goldie roger
roger's character was inspired by two
real pirates
olivier levasseur i hope that's correct
and henry
every levation became known for tossing
a cryptogram from his execution platform
into the crowd telling everyone that the
hidden message on it would lead them to
his gigantic treasure
that to this day has not been found now
this of course directly parallels
roger's legendary speech at his
execution
but it also seems like a likely
inspiration for the poneglyphs
stones written in a long forgotten
language that lead to the last island of
the grand line love tale where the one
piece itself
is
the other pirate avery on the other hand
became famous for being the richest
pirate in the world earning him the
epithet
king of the pirates and yet despite
having
the highest bounty in history of around
700 us dollars in today's currency
placed on his head he vanished with the
legendary treasure that he accumulated
of his life
in the caribbean which at that time used
to be known as
the new world coincidence i think not
avery was the inspiration for a new
generation of notorious pirates
including blackbeard bartholomew roberts
calcio jack samuel bellamy and edward
lowe who all were children at the time
and i know what you're thinking now
hey ohara this dude's nose looks exactly
like a dong well why do you think he
became one of the most
violent pirates of all time exactly
because of comments like that
stop it
raja's role within the story is
extremely interesting in many ways
he quite literally is a legendary pirate
in the sense that
his tale is a story within the story
by doing so oda advances his own world
building
introduces the inspiration for luffy and
many other characters while at the same
time drawing a number of parallels
between the nested story of roger
and the main storyline of luffy roger's
character right from the start explains
why so many people in this world are
pirates next to the injustice of the
world government of course
interestingly enough however the more we
learn about him and the people around
him
unlike in many other stories where the
real deal can't live up to the legend in
roger's case
he kind of becomes even more impressive
a person
the more we learn about him one of the
strongest and most free-spirited
characters in the story
not bound by anything or anyone and of
course the more we learn about him
the more we see the parallels between
him and
luffy
first of all i think it's really
interesting to see that the apparently
unattainable goal that luffy has at the
beginning of the story
in other words becoming pirate king has
already been achieved by this
other legendary character in fact all
the things that come with this title
that usually should be unique to the
main character of the story
have all been done before finding love
tale at the end of the grand line
learning the true history of the world
and discovering the biggest treasure out
there literally from the get-go
we're being told that all of these
things have already
been achieved by some other dude 20
years ago
kind of unexciting for luffy to then
just repeat what roger has
already done however when you really
think about it what this
pretty much guarantees for us is that
luffy will in some shape or
form overcome raja and his legacy in
other words he will do what even the
first pirate king himself could not
do which most likely is change the
unjust world order
[Music]
we actually know for a fact that while
both luffy and roger share the same
dream
this stream is not actually becoming
pirate king
that title didn't even exist before
roger in the first place
rather whatever this dream is it will
have something to do with the main theme
of the story freedom
and while raja managed to live a life of
freedom with his crew
luffy will be the one to bring it to
everyone in whatever shape or form that
will be and that's why the parallels
between them are
so important the same hats inherited
from roger
the same will of d both carry in their
name the voices of all things
they're inclusive and quirky crews and
even parts of their personality seem to
match
as luffy and roger share a number of
lines throughout the story as well
when you look at luffy as an adult he
even looks like roger bits
at the same time of course they aren't
the same person as we have seen
throughout the odin flashback in wano
for instance
while similar yes luffy and roger are
still definitely different people and
luffy
certainly is the tuned up version of
some of the traits that made roger so
special in the first place
and as we now know raja was waiting for
someone like luffy to appear
most likely after abandoning his crew in
anticipation of his death
he instructed his remaining crew to look
for the one who could become the new
pirate king
and finish what he couldn't
just think about it for a moment crocus
and rayleigh are both positioned
suspiciously strategically
at the entrances of both the grand line
and the new world respectively
keeping an eye out for whoever enters
and when we meet both of them
they both go and make explicit
comparisons between raj and luffy and
then of course there is shanks who
surely didn't bet his arm on a little
boy just on a whim
he is certain that luffy will ring in a
new age
[Music]
so it's extremely likely i think that
raja entrusted him with his hat
to find his successor and entrust that
hat to him
in return
[Music]
and this is pretty much already the very
first reason that roger earned himself
this ridiculous bounty of 5.5
billion barry being the only known
person in the story so far to reach love
tale and learn the real history
he possesses knowledge that the world
government has
actively tried to eradicate for
centuries and
not in the nice hey let's all just not
talk about it sort of way but more as in
if you so much as try to learn just a
little bit about the past
we will come without magma psychopath
and burn your whole damn island to the
ground sort of way
as rayleigh tells us raj and his crew
learned about the true history which
without any other factors involved would
probably already save him a top position
on the bounty board
[Music]
i mean just look at what happened to
robin when she was not even a teenager
but on top of that
raja had both the intent to act upon
that knowledge
and the power to actually do so i mean
the guy clashed with anyone who's known
to be strong in the story
garp whitebeard kaido shiki big mom
rocks himself
what a goddamn monster
there are usually three ways to raise
your bounty in the one piece worlds
be extremely strong be extremely
influential or actively try to work
against the established world order well
as you know raja did all three of these
things
quite successfully i would say and so
it's no real surprise that the most
legendary character in one piece ended
up with the
most legendary bounty
now if this wasn't enough legendary old
guy for you yet
i strongly recommend you watch this
video on rayleigh or
this one on garb next thanks for
watching